Jack hey Neil we got another explainer
video to do I too enjoy the explain like
them that's very nice I do because I
learned things okay that's good today's
what what is it yes big numbers oh okay
let's work our way there okay I don't
think I don't think people appreciate
how big astronomically large numbers are
okay of course astronomical as an
adjective is reserved for big things and
big uncountable quantities okay there's
a reason for that and I want to
elucidate this for you first we have to
introduce exponential notation okay okay
so that's the number 10 raised to a
power right right so a 10 to the third
power is 10 times 10 times 10 right
which is a thousand right it's a 10 to
the third powers of thousand ten to the
fourth powers ten thousand dollars a
hundred times 10 to the sixth power it's
a one with six zeros it's a million
million okay are we together well good
okay these are all the the dream numbers
of my bank account so no problem
relating to this all right so the the
number of thousand is pretty familiar to
us all the populations of most cities is
numbered in the thousands you know ten
thousand hundred thousand five hundred
thousand this sort of thing let's go up
by another factor of a thousand so a
thousand times a thousand our 10 to the
sixth power that's a million right the
largest cities in the world are measured
in millions okay I'm native of New York
City we're eight and a half million or
something such as that today let's go up
by another factor of a thousand so we go
from a thousand times a thousand gets to
a million right times another thousand
we add another three zeroes we get to
what a billion billion a thousand
million we have a thousand million and
that gives us a billion that gives you a
billion that's correct
and so that's Carl sake
his favorite number billions
that's his favorite number it shows up a
lot in astronomy okay there 400 between
two and four hundred billion stars in
our galaxy there might be as many as a
hundred billion galaxies in the universe
that billion shows up a lot okay well
let's try to further understand this
okay so how much money does Jeff Bezos
have today I think he's worth eighty
something bill you so let's round that
to 100 billion okay so now here we go
suppose I had 100 billion $1 bills all
right okay and I will be your friend for
life so what what can I do with a
hundred billion dollar bills well I can
take them and put them into end and I
can go around the earth 200 times
wow that's a lot to I'd returned well
wait but I have some leftover money okay
you still have money left alone yes okay
okay so now I'm gonna make put them
vertically and see how high they go well
with what's left over after you went
around the world 200 times you can go
vertically to the moon and back ten
times wait a minute
that's in addition to going around two
times no 200 times
wait you are going around the earth two
hundred times yes and then with the
money left over left over layover now
you please stack Nashville to the
balloon a mountain and back correct
times correct oh yeah that's insane
correct my mattress money got me to the
moon and back that's the left over cash
other things McDonald's used to keep
track of how many hamburgers they sold
do you remember this yes billions very
up to 12 billion 30 billion 50 then he
just gave up and you know if they say
now billions and billions okay so let's
go up by another factor of a thousand
from a billion there which is nine zeros
to now we go to twelve zeros so billion
we had by what would come after by but
the try-try trillion trillion so ten to
the twelfth power is a trillion okay
about a trillion seconds have passed
since cave dwellers painted on cave
walls okay
here's why that's significant because
you can actually count to a billion in
your lifetime and I celebrated my
billion second I don't know if you did
but I celebrated my billions I'm aware
you were I'll tell you this much I
missed it like that
so you you live you're building the
second between your 31st year and your
32nd year of life
so I counted that out and I had a real
fast little sip of champagne and that
was my billion second so if you can turn
that one one number per second for every
second you're alive and don't sleep and
you can do it in 31 years so how long
will it take to count to a trillion
let's see
you know you need another thousand it's
a thousand times that an outright you
need another thousand on top of us so
you got a thousand times so you're not
gonna make it
yes so you need a thousand times 31
years to get there how long is that
thirty one thousand years thousand yet
yeah they though so if you want to give
a kid a task because they're you know
your kids so count to a trillion tell
you there you go a better yet just make
it a billion and see them and and and
keep him going for 30 count a billion so
let's go up another factor of a thousand
so we go from that billion trillion
that's 12 zero so what would be the next
number if you're keeping it really odd
trillion
and that has 9 12 15 zeros that's was
one game conceivable I'm getting there
we haven't you know inconceivable yet so
15 zeros that's a thousand times bigger
than a trillion okay okay a quadrillion
about a hundred quadrillion I calculated
this is the estimated number of sounds
and words ever uttered by all humans who
have ever lived say that again
cuz that that was a weird thing you just
said okay a quadrille you about a
hundred quadrillion and not a hundred
quadrillion is about the estimated
number of sounds and words ever uttered
by all humans who have ever lived
that doesn't include flatulence though
and I have to have a separate term for
congressional filibusters they're in
there too so you want to get a sense of
the scale of these numbers I'm just
putting it in context here in a cosmic
perspective let's go up by another
factor of a thousand so we now have a
number a thousand times bigger than all
the words ever uttered so we went from a
trillion really a trillion quadrillion
quintillion quintillion quintillion so
that's a 1 with 18 zeros okay that's
about the number of grains of sand on an
average Beach oh just one beach why does
one beach just what just next time you
go to beach just pick up yeah a handful
of sand and just look at it yeah and
then if the sand is deep and it goes
into the water a bit and it comes out
and it's wide so you do the volumes you
get you to figure that out that's how
you get a quintillion grains of sand on
an average beach okay but we're not done
I'm not done with you yeah okay listen
can you handle the truth okay you know I
can't I can't
I'm gonna say the truth this just that's
just go ahead okay I'm given months we
left Jeff Bezos long ago in this rank
I'm telling it like this guy's broke
I wouldn't even stop to rob him on the
street he's like dad let's go now a
thousand times bigger than a quintillion
okay so Quinton he was 10 to the 18th
power won with 18 zeros now we're
talking about one with 21 zeros okay
that has a name
next up sextillion sex till you won with
21 zeros that is the estimated number of
stars in the universe a sextillion yes
say yes so that's a thousand times
larger than the number of grains of sand
on a beach
that's a which is itself a thousand
times larger than all the sounds and
words ever uttered actually it's about
ten times larger then it sounds of words
ever uttered by all humans who have ever
lived you take that all the way down so
these are factors larger not just
additive increments but factors
increments but let's keep going I'm not
done with you ten to the 23rd power you
met that number in your chemistry class
in high school
6.02 times 10 to the 23rd power that's a
mole in chemistry okay and a mole is how
many particles of substance occupy a
specified mass of that substance okay a
mole unknown okay
and so they're vessels that contain
moles of things 10 to the 23rd molecules
so here you go you ready do you realize
there are more molecules of water in a
glass of water then there are glasses of
order in all the world's oceans the more
molecules of water in a glass of water
than there are glasses of water in the
entire volume of water in the world
correct okay you know what I'm gonna
drink to that
okay so well it not only that there are
more molecules of air in a single breath
of air
then there are breaths of air in all the
world's atmosphere Wow
okay so what this means that's not just
a fun fact what this means is when I
drink a glass of water and then it comes
out of me seven different ways okay I
can sweat its last bit okay all this it
goes back into the environment okay this
is Earth gotten really discussed there
there are enough molecules that I have
just expelled to repopulate all the
world's water supply with some of the
molecules that were in the glass that I
just drank so here's what we've learned
people when you drink a glass of water
and you're drinking Neil deGrasse Tyson
spit no given enough time it has to
remix to the earth yeah that takes time
so if you go if you can get a character
from long enough ago whoever your hero
is is it Socrates is a Joan of Arc is it
Jesus just go far enough back in time as
you consider them you correct you in the
glass of water you drink there is water
molecules that pass through the kidneys
of Jesus there air molecules that were
breathed by Genghis Khan there and so in
that way we are deeply connected in the
fluids we consume and in the air we
breathe that is so cool that is one of
the coolest facts we have ever divulged
on this show and you can have that with
10 to the 23 molecules scattered back
into the atmosphere or into the waters
of the world it's all about a mole now
how do we take that and find out how we
recycle jeff's be so smaii into my
benefit okay Chuck I'll get to work on
that equation please do so working up
from the mole we get to 10 to the 81st
power if you multiply all the stars and
times all the molecules and particles
they're made of you get 10 to the 81
power which is the sum of all particles
that comprise the observable universe
that's cool
now you can ask why would anyone need a
number bigger than this
I was gonna say there's nothing else
beyond that beyond that to count yeah
right what is there to count beyond that
okay but that doesn't stop
mathematicians so there's a number a one
with a hundred zeros nice round with
their be 10 to the hundredth power
that's called a Google the company took
that word messed up the spelling of it
and they became the first time most
people even ever heard the pronunciation
of such a thing
gugus one with 100 zeros that is 10 to
the 19th power larger than the number of
particles in the entire universe that's
not right that's that's all right so
what's the use of that well we'll get
there how about a number that Dwarfs the
Google the Google well how would you
write out at Google you put a 1 and 100
zeros right okay ten to the hundredth
power means there's a number that Dwarfs
the Google that's ten to the Google
power and as that called a Yahoo no 10
to the middle power is a one with a
googol zeroes and that's called the
Googleplex
oh sweet the Googleplex now here's the
problem with the Googleplex how many
zeros does it have if you were to write
it out more zeros than let's see more
zeros then it would take your child to
write out after you sent them to the
corner for a time I count to a billion
so if 10 to the hundredth is a Google
and it's a one with a hundred zeros then
10 to the Google power is a one with how
many zeros
it has a googol zeros if what's in the
exponent is how many zeros you have
right 10 to the 21 had 21 zeros 10 to
the 81 had 81 zeros 10 to the hundredth
that Google has a hundred zeros 10
the Google is a one with a googol zeroes
that's a googolplex here's my point if a
googolplex has a googol zeroes in it
right there are not enough particles in
the universe upon which you would write
the zeros just to express that number so
there's not room for a googolplex to be
written now written in full form in the
universe that's correct
if you look if you put a 0 on every
particle in the universe you can't you
don't have you've run out of room to
write the Google Plus correct that's
insane that's insane it's completely
insane
is the Googleplex it's a big number so
we went through all this to say it's a
big number that's what the session is
about check big numbers thing did you
get the rhythm and see how full sir I'm
we're full circles bigger numbers all
right so now why do you have big numbers
at all because you know order counting
things you're counting in one way in one
use of them you're counting events so
for example there is a number that
Dwarfs the Googleplex
it's called skews number it's called
it's 10 to the 10th to the 10th to the
34th power
it's called skews number okay now that
number Dwarfs the Googleplex and you can
only write it this way with these sort
of exponents up there okay well because
this there's not enough room in the
universe to write it any other way
exactly okay that's about the total
number of combinations of how you would
orient the matter in the universe and so
forth so for example if I take a
molecule within you and swap it with a
molecule in me that's a configuration of
the universe I take something from alpha
century and swap it with with Omega set
e5 which is a fictional place from Star
Trek swap those atoms that's another
config swap 10 atoms here in there
that's another configure
it's the number of combinations of
particle configurations in the universe
I that is pretty cool well again you're
not counting things you're counting
events it's like asking how many
possible chess games are there right
right
chess only has you know eight six 32
pieces in it and 64 squares right all
right so so there you have it Chuck I
just wanted to give you a sense of what
big numbers are and whatever is the big
number you thought the big number was
they're bigger numbers bigger than that
right right well but I have what I have
taken away from this is Jeff besos isn't
as rich as I thought huh these are broke
he's broke broke ass pesos so Chuck
there you have it the cosmic perspective
of big numbers sweet yes all right
this has been another explainer video
from star talking on the OL deGrasse
Tyson
[Music]